وبحث امير قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال
الثاني مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني
بلينكن الاوضاع في القطاع والاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله خلال زياره الاخير
للدوحه وقال الديوان الاميري القطري ان
امير قطر شدد خلال اللقاء على ضروره تضافر
الجهود الاقليميه والدوليه للوصول الى وقف
اطلاق النار وحمايه المدنيين واستمرار
ادخال المساعدات بشكل كاف ومستدام الى كل
مناطق القطاع كما اشار الديوان الاميري
الى ان بلينكن شكر امير قطر على جهود
الدوحه المتواصله لاستئناف تبادل
الاسرع من جانبه قال رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن الثاني انه استعرض خلال لقائه مع
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين واضاف رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري في تغريده
له على منصه اكس ان الجانبين اكدا على
هميه دور وساطه قطر وشركائها الدوليين في
التوصل الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار في غزه
الخارجيه القطريه قالت ان الجانبين ناقشا
مستجدات الاوضاع في القطاع والاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله واتساع دائره العنف في
المنطقه وتداعياته على الامن والاستقرار
الاقليمي والعالمي كما ناقش جهود الجانبين
للتوصل الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار في
القطاع بما يمهد لحل عادل وشامل ومستدام
القضيه الفلسطينيان الجانبان بحثا ايضا
استئناف عمليه تبادل المحتجزين بين
اسرائيل وحركه حماس كما ناقش تسريع وتيره
ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه الى القطاع مع
زيادتها نظرا للاحتياجات الملحه والعاجله
لا سما من الماء والغذاء والدواء واضافت
الخارجيه القطريه ان رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري اكد خلال لقائه مع بلينكن
ان انهاء العدوان على غزه لم يعد مطلب
لسكان القطاع فحسب بل اصبح مطلبا لكل شعوب
المنطقه
والعالم